thanks to our military
and our allies
and the brave fighters of afghanistan
the taliban regime
is coming to an end by the end of this
year the transition will be complete and
afghans will take full responsibility
for their security and our combat
mission will be over what are we going
to say we'll stay for another 21 years
and we'll stay for another 50. the whole
thing is
ridiculous we're bringing troops back
home from afghanistan is a taliban
takeover of afghanistan now inevitable
no
it is not
but it is happening
the taliban is taking control of
afghanistan
currently as of today 240 districts uh
the taliban controls and there are some
contested areas but kandahar the second
largest city has fallen herat ghazni all
have fallen and now the u.s is putting
more troops in
marines and other troops to be able to
get americans out
of afghanistan four different presidents
almost 20 years
and now this is how this is coming to an
end in afghanistan let's bring in our
panel ben dominic publisher of the
federalist mara liason national
political correspondent of national
public radio and washington post
columnist mark thiessen mark you wrote
some speeches at the beginning of that
the war
and throughout uh it is just talking to
general keane and others it's tough to
watch
it is tough to watch and you and i
travel together to a bunch of those
cities you just named uh when you were a
pentagon correspondent and i was working
in the pentagon for secretary rumsfeld
and it's heartbreaking to to to see
what's unfolding over there but if you
want to understand just how pathetic
this administration's afghan policy is
here's a story here's the lead of a
story that's on the new york times
website right now just just went up a
little a couple hours ago american
negotiators are trying to extract
assurances from the taliban that they
will not attack the u.s embassy in kabul
if the extremist group takes over the
country's government and ever wants to
receive u.s foreign aid
the biden administration is dangling u.s
foreign aid to the people who aided and
abetted the attacks of september 11
2001. if they please please pretty
please don't attack the u.s embassy that
is the probably in my entire career in
washington is the most pathetic thing
i've ever seen uh when a expression of
weakness i've ever seen when it comes to
u.s foreign policy
well to that point the messaging mara
changed dramatically over 24 hours i had
john kirby a pentagon spokesperson on
last night
and he was saying that the part of the
the give and take is to have the taliban
understand that they risk
being
a pariah in the world here's that
exchange
the taliban continues to try to advance
uh in the country through brutality
through oppression through fear those
kinds of tactics are not going to lead
to the level of legitimacy that they say
they want from the international
community that's why we continue to
admiral i mean i mean do you think the
taliban is going to say we're going to
we want to be legitimate in the world's
eyes that that's going to be the threat
that makes them stop beheading or
executing people bret they've said from
themselves that they want legitimacy and
that they want to have a hand in
governance which means they're going to
have to come to the table and be part of
a negotiated political settlement
but clearly mar that's not not happening
and now u.s troops are going in
uh and that's a danger in and of itself
it's a danger in and of itself they're
going in to get americans out safely but
this is a tragedy from top to bottom
every way you look at this i mean we
were in afghanistan for 20 years the
purpose originally was to deny al-qaeda
a safe haven to launch terrorist attacks
against the united states it seems like
we've accomplished that we haven't had
any attacks from there but after 20
years of pouring resources and training
into afghanistan their own security
forces are still not able to defend
their own territory you've had
consecutive administrations you just
played all those sound bites two
american presidents wanted out two
american administrations decided that
having american troops in afghanistan
was not in the national security
interest of the united states and the
american people are first of all tired
of it they don't want american troops
there they also don't understand what
we're doing there yeah just in the last
few minutes we got word that secretary
blinken and secretary austin state and
defense secretaries had a call with the
afghan president ashraf ghani they are
saying that they are committed to the
state stability and security of
afghanistan ben but they're also
privately shooting down
stories or rumors that they asked ghani
to resign
thoughts about this as it's evolving
just over the past couple days
you know i'm a child of the 80's brett
and uh and i'm my siblings uh and my
brothers-in-law have spent far more time
in afghanistan than anyone on this panel
and i was talking to my brother right
before i came on and i said what what
would you like me to say and he said
what do you expect what do you expect
after all of this okay a policy that was
misbegotten in terms of its anticipation
of trying to achieve things in
afghanistan that may be unachievable
blood that cries out from the ground
there i think in terms of wasted
resources and lives when it came to
american policy and i think a failed
definition of victory
in so many different respects and across
multiple and bipartisan administrations
we've had three presidents in a row
elected based on arguing against the
wars in the middle east and in
afghanistan it seems to me that the
neoconservative agenda that cares so
much about democracy overseas is not
very interested in listening to it here
at home and i think instead what we
ought to be asking is if this was
something that we wanted to achieve
where we had a clear goal how could it
have been argued better how could it
have been managed better and how could
have the policies actually lined up with
what we wanted to achieve as opposed to
this embarrassing end mark i want to
give you the last word but before i do
i'm going to read a little something
from the independence fund and that is
this is really painful for a lot of
people right now gold star families
veterans families who've all endured
sacrificed there
and they say a lot of hearts are heavy
right now their phones are flooded with
veterans who are really struggling with
this information about afghanistan and
trying to come to grips with it and
we're going to put up on that on the
screen the veterans crisis uh hotline
on the bottom of the screen if you want
to talk to somebody uh through this mark
last word quickly
yeah so uh we're seeing history repeat
itself joe biden is the guy who presided
over the disastrous use withdrawal from
iraq um which led to the rise of isis
caliphate the size of great britain and
a terrorist network that spread his
tentacles and carried out attacks in in
29 countries and killed more than 2 000
people around the world and by the way
khalid sheikh mohammed predicted this he
told his cia negotiator his ci
interrogator in his cell in a black site
we will win because americans don't
realize we don't need to defeat you
militarily we only need to fight long
enough for you to lose by defeating
yourself by quitting
all right sad day uh for for that hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else